I don't think I'm overstating it when I say that the last two seasons of anime were some of the best we've seen in years.
So Spring 2019 has a lot to live up to.
So, what could possibly be carrying this season?
Well, looking at the chart, it should be pretty obvious,
I mean- because this season, we have
the one,
the ONLY,
Miru Tights.
It's a show about girls...
wearing wet tights.
It's a SHOW,
about GIRLS,
wearing WET TI-
*slams desk*
[farther from the mic]
(People!)
(Have you not seen the light!)
Hmmmmmm.
*weird acapella cover of the usual title sequence theme*
"Koko wa danshi toire.."
"Machigainaku danshi toire da.."
"Ja, naze..."
"Nande koko ni Sensei ga??!?!"
why do I do this to myself.
On one hand, I somehow find myself
watching the second anime suppository scene
in back-to-back seasons of some guy trying
to get with his teacher in
"That's the best part," the Anime,
and on the other hand I'm debating whether it's worth turning this off, and treasuring the small
bit of dignity I still have left
-Shh! Shh, shh!
bit of dignity I still have lef--
[opening theme drawing to a close]
shutup, shutup! this is the best part, this is the best part!
[Final piano notes slowly play out...]
"..darling! ♡"
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡＡ
F*** it. This is the latest show in anime's newest genre,
'I can't believe it's not hentai,'
and I mean, I can't be the only one noticing nowadays
how the line between anime plots and hentai plots is slowly blurring.
At this point you can basically SEE what hentai tags you can add to an anime,
so, why the hell not? Let's see how many tags we can collect this season,
and see how hentai anime has gotten.
𝘐 𝘴𝘸𝘦𝘢𝘳 𝘵𝘰 𝘨𝘰𝘥, 𝘢𝘯𝘪𝘮𝘦, 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘣𝘦𝘵𝘵𝘦𝘳 𝘯𝘰𝘵 𝘥𝘰 𝘪𝘵,
𝘐 𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘯𝘦𝘦𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴 𝘴𝘩** 𝘪𝘯 𝘮𝘺 𝘢𝘯𝘪𝘮𝘦 𝘳𝘪𝘨𝘩𝘵 𝘯𝘰𝘸,
𝘕𝘰𝘣𝘰𝘥𝘺 𝙖𝙨𝙠𝙚𝙙 𝘵𝘰 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘶𝘨𝘭𝘺, 𝘴𝘸𝘦𝘢𝘵𝘺 𝘰𝘨𝘳𝘦𝘴
𝘣𝘢𝘯𝘨 𝘢 𝘣𝘶𝘯𝘤𝘩 𝘰𝘧 𝘪𝘯𝘯𝘰𝘤𝘦𝘯𝘵 𝘭𝘰𝘭𝘪𝘴 𝘣𝘶𝘵 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘬𝘦𝘦𝘱 𝘥𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘪𝘵 𝙖𝙣𝙮𝙬𝙖𝙮,
𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘋𝘖 𝘪𝘵,
𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵
𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘧****𝘯𝘨 𝘋𝘖 𝘪𝘵,
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛 𝘧****𝘕𝘎
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛 𝘧****𝘕𝘎 𝘊𝘏𝘜𝘕𝘎𝘜𝘚
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛 𝘧****𝘕𝘎 𝘊𝘏𝘜𝘕𝘎𝘜𝘚 𝘐'𝘮 𝘨𝘰𝘯𝘯𝘢 𝘓𝘌𝘈𝘝𝘌,
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛 𝘧****𝘕𝘎 𝘊𝘏𝘜𝘕𝘎𝘜𝘚 𝘐'𝘮 𝘨𝘰𝘯𝘯𝘢 𝘓𝘌𝘈𝘝𝘌, 𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘋𝘖 𝘐𝘛
[menacing aura completely dissapears]
𝘐𝘧 𝘐 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘧𝘈𝘛 𝘧****𝘕𝘎 𝘊𝘏𝘜𝘕𝘎𝘜𝘚 𝘐'𝘮 𝘨𝘰𝘯𝘯𝘢 𝘓𝘌𝘈𝘝𝘌, 𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘋𝘖 𝘐𝘛-Oh my god..!
Thi's beatiful!..
I have the biggest nostalgia boner right now!
..it's like an erection straight to my childhood..~
(Uuuuh, couldn't you have worded that a bit better?)
*starts sobbing*
(are you... Are you crying?)
*sniff* I'm not crying.... These are just the precum of my soul~
Man, what's the time period we are living in
right now ?
It feels weird that it's 2019 and one of the biggest shows this season, is Fruits Basket
But in this age of new season announcements and remakes
Let it sink in that your favorite older anime is probably more likely to get another season or remake now
than it did when it aired like a decade ago
So that's right boys! The dream isn't dead yet!
You know what? I actually wanted to give a quick shoutout to china
because I saw this clip the other day in a chinese-made anime and this is by far the best CG crowds I've seen
I didn't even notice it was CG until someone pointed it out
and if you really concentrate, it does look a bit stiff, It's not perfect but DEAR LORD we're finally making strides
*quick intermission*
OH GOD WHY HAVE YOU FORSAKEN US?! WHY HAVE YOU PUT ME BACK IN BAD CG HELL?!
*soft crying*
I thought we were making progress. I THOUGHT WE WERE MAKING PROGRESS!
*gasp*
*kick to the face*
Hey, it's a show called Demon Slayer about a guy who slays demons
and would you look at that, it's been an entire episode and no one's been violently assaulted so I don't have to
add any more suspect tags!
*away from mic*
DON'T DO IT! I SWEAR TO GOD ANIME I'M FUCKING LEAVING DON'T FUCKING DO IT!
But I've got to say, Ufotable have done it again.
And I was sold seeing this absolutely gorgeous, beautifully directed dynamic
Little sister
*light cough*
On a serious note though, it's cool to see another Shonen Jump title
getting the premium treatment from Ufotable this time
and once again, I mean, it's Ufotable. It looks slick, the action scenes are exhilarating,
integrating the trademark Ufotable CG and dynamic camera
and I'm just happy to hear a Yukie Kagawa score come again, even if it sounds eerily similar
to Hawa
Fairy Gone? More like, Fairly Gone from my memory,
ha ha ha ha, *gasp*,
no seriously, this show is so painfully forgettable I really don't have much to say about it.
Uh-oh...
I've seen enough anime to know where THIS is going!
*click*
HaHA! Check MATE, Officer!
You can't ARREST me,
If I'm Already ARRESTED!
Look, lets be honest, when you see a character design like this
paired with the words
800 YEAR OLD FOXGIRL
your first reaction is probably to think something dodgy is up
and hope to god that it's not your penis
But dear lord the helpful fox senko-san is just one wholesome-ass show
Watching an episode is like the real life equivalent to eating a senzu bean
Your just watching a stressed out, overworked salary man
Being pampered by a fox-loli
and its the closest to real life HP recovery your gonna get
this is like fan service for the SOUL
I mean just LOOK AT THIS TAIL
AAAAAH THE, GOD, AAAAAGH IM HAVING A FLUFFGASM
Hey, I heard you liked isekai,
so I took an isekai,
an isekai,
and an isekai
than isekai'd
the isekai
to another isekai,
░i░s░ ░t░h░i░s░ ░i░s░e░k░a░i░ ░e░n░o░u░g░h░ ░f░o░r░ ░y░o░u░?░
I really didn't think I'd like this as much as I do.
I lied. I liked this EXACTLY as much as I thought I would,
but didn't want to admit to myself.
I mean, it's just a glorified isekai fanfiction-
who would've thought that seeing isekai characterss banter with each other could be so enjoyable?
'cause, you got all your favorite characters here!
Kazuma,
Ainz-sama,
Aqua,
Emilia,
Subaru,
whoever this is,
Truck-kun,
Oh, there he is!
There's my boy again!
Of course this season won't be
complete without at least one new Isekai
alright, whaddowe got next?
I'm GAY NOW!
Where do I even start with this one?
WHAT TAG DOES THIS EVEN BELONG TO???
So welcome to the latest drug-induced brainfart of Kunihiko Ikuhara,
whose works include the likes of Mawaru-Penguindrum and Revolutionary Girl Utena,
which, if you're familiar with, will give you a much better sense of what you're getting into
than anything I could say right now.
I don't think it's *actually* possible to sum up this anime in a single sentence,
but I'm gonna damn well try anyway:
Imagine if Monogatari and Yuri on Ice
Imagine if Monogatari and Yuri on Ice had a Persona-flavored
Imagine if Monogatari and Yuri on Ice had a Persona-flavored frog baby that was anally conceived
Imagine if Monogatari and Yuri on Ice had a Persona-flavored frog baby that was anally conceived in Bollywood.
You're watching three boys get transformed into frogs or kappas
when they get eaten butt-first by another kappa
as they enter people's anuses in order to consume their desire.
They're kinda like the Phantom Thieves, except instead of producing a change of heart,
they just eat ass,
it's about eating ass,
yes, someone FINALLY MADE AN ANIME about
yes, someone FINALLY MADE AN ANIME about ＥＡＴＩＮＧ ＡＳ－
Inuhara's work is famous for being very out there on the surface level
requiring you to dig through its many layers to come to your own conclusion,
which is this definitely is, but that's currently the appeal of it.
I mean, you look at something like this, and
m a y b e you see a message about hidden desires
explored through the lens of traditional Japanese folklore
with a side of homoeroticism
set in a technologically reliant modern day,
ORR you might just see Avengers Endgame spoilers.
I would say I enjoyed it, but
that would imply my brain had rationalized the experience to something close enough to resembling a coherent thought.
"Okay."